the dealer would have transformed the UK
shopping center market is off that was
Hammerson the company we are North
London's Brent Cross & Birmingham's
bullring launching a 3.4 billion pound
takeover of into the owner of
Manchester's Trafford Centre Jamison is
no longer recommending the deal it says
the markets view of the retail property
set to have deteriorated since it
launched its bit into called the
explanation unsatisfactory with me now
Lawrence Hutchings he's chief executive
of Capital Regional which owns shopping
centers nationwide and what Williams
he's president of the retail Property
Organization Revo so gentlemen good
evening to you both Mar let me start
with you I mean Hammerson was a
diversified pan-european play this was
doubling down on the UK shopping center
market did that surprise you the two
good companies and they put forward
their statement about merging and using
management expertise to combine and
they've obviously announced that due to
the deterioration in the retail market
that it's no longer in shelled as best
interests but clearly Hammerson
shareholders hated this deal didn't they
you'd have to talk to us and shelled as
the fact is the market has deteriorated
into the retail scene which we would
agree with and that's clearly now given
us a reason for not proceeding but I
mean you know this deal was announced
just before Christmas last year you
think there's been that stock a
deterioration in just a short period of
time the market has changed on a
sixpence we have seen a number of retail
failures and we can go into the reasons
why but companies like new-look Maplin
Toys R Us they have had a big impact and
we've seen a lot of job losses
I mean Lawrence all of all of those
three that Mark mentioned our tenants in
some of your centers aren't they we had
very limited exposure to be honest we
had one towards are asked to Maplin
stores and fortunately we've not seen a
huge impact from the new-look
restructuring but I think the key issue
here is that it's not all negative from
the high street and if you look at the
trends and analyze them in more detail
we are seeing growth in football in our
shopping centers and we are certainly
seeing a move down the pricing
architecture towards the value into the
spectrum and that's evidenced by the
performance of retailers like little for
example Aldi superdrug Primark who have
all performed well so we're not we're
not denying that it's tough out there
but it
it's I guess what we're saying is it's
not tough everywhere necessarily there
are bright points and certainly from our
perspective the types of centers we
invest in are not the large flagship
locations typically they they're the
community centers and we think we're
very well positioned in terms of the
structural changes that are taking place
in retailing and this polarization that
we mentioned between the large venues
which are increasing about experience
and then the smaller venues which are
about local and community shopping needs
based more value orientated I mean your
annex Hammerson man were you surprised
that they did this deal that they
embarked on it I'm still a Hammerson
shareholder and I think the the
economies of scale and our industry are
proven so if you look what's happened in
the US for example in North America with
the mergers that salmon have undertaken
for example over the years and General
Growth Properties if you look at what's
happened in Canada if you look at what's
happened even in Central Europe with uni
bi and the rudenko Tire
I think economy there's no doubt we're
in the doors businesses I'm fond of
saying so there are economies in scale
so that sort of it I felt was compelling
if I'm honest there was a lot of
commentary during this whole saga about
into properties being under invested I
mean it writ and it really rang called
with both sides they said the city
analysts that cover these two stocks
haven't necessarily been to some of the
centers I mean that's a competitor of
theirs do you see them investing
I think the shopping centers by nature
and as we mentioned where the structural
change is happening in our industry they
do consume capital we're very fortunate
they were able to deploy the capex
or capital into our shopping centers on
a creative basis but for many the sort
of capital investment in transforming
these locations into experience based
locations often isn't as a creative so I
I hear the arguments about about the
into portfolio but I think it's pretty
consistent for our industry in yeah I
mean this is the thing mark these
centers are like it's like painting the
Forth Bridge isn't it you've got to keep
investing in these big centers you've
got to keep enhancing what Lawrence just
refer to the experience for customers
for shoppers well the retail scene has
changed you know we there's an
acknowledgement we have too much retail
floor space the Internet has had an
impact that structural there's no point
in going back
town centers tend to be seen as a proxy
for retail but the reality is their
places their mixed use and we've got
almost going back over century to when
they were places where people lived it
worked and shopped and we've got to move
more to that mixed use environment so
what's next for into I mean their share
price has dropped four percent on this
news today Hamilton's is up conversely
by four percent into stock prices now
trading at something like forty eight
percent to the value of its assets I
mean clearly the market thinks that the
valuations in its books are too high
well the market always values in the way
the market does and you have the
independent valuations the reality is
all owners of centers are going to have
to and are investing in their assets and
it's how they evolve into something
that's more mixed juice that's different
to it to where it was ten years ago I'm
an interesting position here is you've
got John Whittaker who's the big
shareholder in into the former owner of
Trafford Centre he traded it for a
bigger stake in the enlarged into very
much a prime mover behind this deal he's
going to be sitting there pretty peeved
tonight isn't he
I have no idea how he's going to feel
but I think that statement it
illustrates the slight annoyance yes but
I mean do you think John Whittaker might
now be sort of talking to bankers and
saying well how long we could take this
thing private absolutely no idea but
yeah the markets will do take that and
the other interesting twist in this saga
Lawrence was French company Clair PA
mentioned Simon the u.s. property giant
just now in their big shareholder in
clay Pierre they came in with an offer
for Hamilton Hammerson Hammerson batted
it away clay Pierre walked away last
week is it possible do you think that
they're going to come back in six months
time I think anything's possible you do
get the feeling that we haven't seen the
end of this round of effectively
consolidation in the industry the
Westfield unis by consolidation it feels
like there will be more consolidation on
industry across market so pan European
for example as I mentioned following
what's happened in other global markets
like Canada and North America why is so
is consolidation so important for the
sector though it's as I've mentioned
it's a proven model so
with relationships with retailers
improve as as your scale grows as you've
got more touch points with your retailer
customers for example the nature of
procurement with your suppliers improves
as you've got more scale affecting your
buying power and you're also able to
attract better talent and retain better
talent in these larger organizations we
can provide more opportunity what about
the consumer climate just now I mean
you've both mentioned it's pretty tough
out there but there are pockets of
growth Primark very good example
very good trading statement from them
yesterday now that we're seeing wages
overtaking inflation is that going to
potentially help do you think it
certainly won't hinder fundamentally a
recovery with the consumer in the UK and
as we've mentioned previously there are
cyclic all and structural pressures on
the high street at the moment and it
certainly feels as though that the
psychical pressures are starting to move
in the right direction as you've
mentioned with the announcement today
about real wage growth I think that's a
real plus for the high street now do you
think any geographical variances at all
we certainly see in London and London
connected economies performing a little
better
for example than than other places in
the country however the the real
difference that we're seeing is where
we've invested in customer propositions
so improving the centres whether it's by
merchandising or improving services we
are seeing an increase in footfall when
I was up with green the other week which
is one of yours of course it seemed as
busy as ever and I was searching smart
Williams thanks but thank you